so welcome I don't know who think in
Italy maybe the hot Mediterranean blood
is not they say mr. Poirot this
complains when a holiday is coming up
don't you do I have been so rarely for
us zombies how kind of it implying
something to people that isn't the case
they found pictures so I'm [ __ ]
talking about what do I ever complain
okay about spending time you and the
girl that wasn't what I meant never I
could probably do is keeping a bit of an
eye on our relationship daddy how do you
mean I'm going to pass good
there's often more but on admirers and
people on the outside are ever aware of
you I suppose they're your cards down on
the table be honest you should stay
[Music]
terrified someone already done this is
the premeditated version
I've been bit temperamentally what do
you mean it's like this constant
conviction that I haven't been get more
like deserve or undervalued
hi hey what's your coat what do you want
to know I need to make sure that you're
not up to something I think you might be
okay I find myself reassessing whether
it ever was proper love you can just
fall how would I love it someone valuing
and own it you know
you